just found that out right before we
walked walked in this uh
to the session so just want to say our
condolences go out to his family
um certainly he's a guy that is held in
the highest regard in this building and
i think
just around the league he's had a
tremendous impact um
not only in people in this building
obviously gowdy and
a lot of our personnel people but people
in other departments as well
his impact is still felt to this day
with when you look at our roster
but i think he's had a tremendous impact
amongst many
people across the league when you look
at all the other gm's that
have learned under him so certainly
we're we're sitting here with heavy
hearts today i've only had a few
opportunities to to meet him over the
last couple years
um but you know i just know
how important he he was to many people
in this building
i feel so blessed that i had the
opportunity to to work with him
just one of the more uh remarkable
people that i've ever
had the privilege to to work with and be
around
i think the one thing that really stands
out to me was just his humility
just it was never about ted
it was always what's best for the
[Music]
organization
ted thompson who served as general
manager of the green bay packers from
2005 through 2017
passed earlier this week at the age of
68 his
work continues to show up in
every aspect of the green bay packers
roster
starting with franchise quarterback
aaron rodgers and peter when you think
back to what was going on in 2005 with
brett favre and he was about two or
three years into the
annual game of what am i going to do the
packers
seemingly exasperated already with it
and having aaron rodgers fall into their
lap we're willing
to put that name on the card and the
rest is history and that was ted
thompson
and you know that legacy will be on
display
this sunday and possibly two weeks later
in tampa bay
mike uh that's the story that's the
clear story i have a memory of ted
thompson about it goes back to brett
favre
and just remember you know in 2008
in the summer of 2008 remember in the
spring
farv retires and then he starts having
second thoughts i want to come back i
want to come back
so right before the start of training
camp when he was
at basically at cross purposes with the
packers
and he was going to report to training
camp i was
at farv's house in mississippi
uh the day or two before he was going to
leave to go back to green bay
and he was going to challenge the
packers hey i'm going to report for
training camp and and i there's this one
time in the kitchen
he you know where he's talking about
talking to me about what his plans are
and that he's going to go in there i
said hey brett you know i'm
i i'm i'm not in the middle of this
believe me
but i'm just telling you ted thompson is
not
backing down period he will not back
down
and i had a phone conversation with ted
thompson
in a couple of weeks earlier where he
essentially said to me
he said if i allow brett to dictate what
he wants to do
and to go to the minnesota vikings you
know in essence he just joked about how
he would be hung in effigy
in green bay and he's absolutely right
you know
hey we love brett he's the greatest he's
he's
he's this guy but at the end of the day
i am the steward of this franchise
and the minnesota vikings are our rivals
and we are not handing brett favre to
the minnesota vikings
period so and and ted thompson
held his ground favre went to the jets
later obviously he goes to the vikings
but farv goes to the jets
and basically he won you know ted
thompson won that
and the other thing i would say mike is
that i found it
so poignant yesterday when i was looking
at the ap
all pro team of 2020
and there the center is corey linsley
the quarterback is aaron rodgers
the uh the wide receiver
is one of the wide receivers is devonte
adams the left tackle
is david bachdiari what do they have in
common all drafted by ted thompson
yeah that's an excellent point and that
was his approach it was draft and
developed draft and developed sometimes
at at the risk of criticism from others
who would say
what about free agents they were always
always very careful about free agents
but
built that team through the draft and
the the product is still there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports